des sourires et des cris de victoire les
38 faucheurs volontaires sortent
satisfaits et tous relaxés
le juge expliquant que l'infraction n'a
pas été caractérisé les faucheurs
estiment que leur action de
désobéissance civique et donc légitimé
la justice reconnaît nos actions de
faucheurs comme étant des bonnes actions
finalement ils sont soumis depuis 2001 à
une réglementation sur les ogm qui
aurait dû avoir lieu c'est à dire de
déclarer le lieu la qualité de ces de
ces semences et de ses récoltes
donc ce qu'on a fait on a fait en sorte
que la loi puisse être appliqué la
relaxe elle montre aussi tous les
défauts qu'il ya autour de ces ogm
cachés qui sont interdits et la cour
européenne de justice a rappelé cet été
voilà l'a montré cet été
en sachant que ce sont des princes 11e
en novembre 2016 un groupe de soixante
sept chars anti ogm s'étaient attaqués à
des parcelles d'essai de colza rendu
résistant aux herbicides à marsannay
darrois en côte d'or pour la coopérative
dijon céréales qui réclamaient les
indemnités ce jugement est un choc
je suis vraiment en colère prend pas ce
qui se passe on a eu un procès dit gens
qui revendiquent leur action qui
revendique avoir violé la propriété
d'autrui
et apparemment ce que j'ai déjà prochain
matin le juge considère que l'infraction
n'est pas caractérisée
c'est excessivement surprenant pour moi
au vu des réquisitions du procureur qui
demandait quand même
condamné il souhaite justement que le
procureur fasse appel de ce jugement
reste que cette décision très attendue
dans le monde agricole n'a pas fini de
faire débat